This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Sam.
And I'm Neil.
In recent years, new diets with names like vegan, keto and paleo have become very popular.
Are you a vegetarian, Neil?
Do you follow any particular diet?
Well, I eat lots of fresh fruit and vegetables and only a little meat from time to time.
Well, while many diets claim to improve health or help you lose weight,
recent research shows that what counts is not what you eat but how your body reacts.
Yes, and that reaction doesn't happen where you might think, not in the brain or tongue
or even the stomach, but in the gut. Another name for the intestines, the long tube inside your
body which digests food. Inside everyone's gut are millions of microbes, tiny living organisms,
too small to see without a microscope. Some of them are good for us, some bad.
Microbes help digest food, but they influence our bodies more than we know.
Think of them as chemical factories that cause our individual reaction to the food we eat.
This mix of gut microbes is unique and different for everyone, even identical twins.
And it's the reason why some doctors now recommend a personalized diet, one that perfectly fits
your own unique combination of microbes. We'll hear more soon, but first I have a question for
you, Neil, and it's about the gut, the tube which includes the large and small intestine.
It's very long, but how long exactly is the average adult's gut? Is it a three and a half meters,
b five and a half meters or c seven and a half meters?
Well, everybody is different, of course, but I'll say on average the gut is b five and a half meters
okay, Neil, I'll reveal the answer later in the program.
Among the first to investigate gut microbes was Dr Tim Specter, author of the best-selling book
The Diet Myth. He wanted to check whether the dietary advice he had heard and believed advice
like eat little and often or avoid fat was really true.
This introduction to Specter explained how he started to doubt some of this advice.
Food myths, he calls them, to BBC Radio 4 program The Life Scientific.
All these so-called myths that I'd believed, whether it was about calories, about fats,
when to eat, how to eat, were based on flimsy or no evidence, very old, very poor quality,
and it had been repeated so much that people didn't think to question them.
One of the food myths Dr Specter questioned was counting calories, the units which
measure the amount of energy food provides. He discovered that much of the dietary advice he had
heard was either incorrect or based on flimsy evidence. If evidence is flimsy, it's weak and
unconvincing. As Dr Specter questioned these food myths, he remembered an earlier study involving
identical twins, pairs of brothers or sisters with the same genes. It was the surprising differences
and weight between one twin and another that made Dr Specter realise that no two people have
the same gut. Even identical twins' guts are different. But as he told BBC Radio 4's The Life
Scientific, the discovery came in a very smelly way by asking his volunteers to send samples of
their poo in the post. We collected lots of these samples, sequenced them, and then looked at twins
where one was overweight and one was skinny. We found in every case the skinnier twin had a more
diverse microbiome, greater numbers of different species. They also had high numbers of a couple
of microbes that just stuck out of the crowd. One was called Christensenella and the other one
was called Akamansia. Although genetically identical one twin was overweight, while the other twin
was skinny or very thin. Because the weight difference could not be explained genetically,
Dr Specter suspected the microbes in the skinnier twin's gut held the answer. The more diverse
someone's microbes, the better their gut was at digesting food, regulating fat and maintaining
health. Two microbes, Christensenella and Akamansia were especially effective. Dr Specter says these
microbes stuck out of the crowd, meaning they were easy to notice for the positive effect.
And since everyone's microbes are different, it follows that a personalized diet which selects
the friendliest food for your gut is best. Right, and all this talk of eating is making me hungry,
so tell me Sam was my answer to your question right? Ah yes, I asked about the length of the
gut in the average adult. I said it was five and a half meters. Which was the correct answer,
well done Neil, that took guts, which is the second meaning of the word, courage.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned starting with gut, an informal word for the intestines,
the tube which digests food from the stomach. Microbes are microscopic organisms living inside the
body. A calorie is a unit measuring how much energy food provides. If an argument or evidence is
flimsy, it's weak and hard to believe. A skinny person is very thin. And finally, if something sticks
out of the crowd, it's noticeable in a good way. Unfortunately our six minutes are up, but remember
look after your gut and your gut will look after you. Goodbye!